revisionismus begann ja das haus kein
weg von revierleiter herzlich willkommen
zurück zu einer weiteren folge minecraft
hero exit blabla die stars und wir gehen
jetzt zusammen schlafen kev richtig
ausgeloggt alu auf meiner seite aus ist
klar geworden dann dann es ist ja jetzt
es heißt ja nicht dass der regen aufhört
doch wenn es hell wird nicht dagegen auf
probleme im bett liegen werde ich lieber
meinen beschluss
du kannst du kannst draufkommen ist also
ja jetzt tag und jetzt wird auch
jährigen auf wieso und jetzt bin ich
hier das ganze haus an schon bitte
einmal mit mir ohne witz statt gelb es
fängt erneut an zu regnen
bei mir nicht aber mir als auch lauf wie
support endlich das wenig das hat immer
geklappt
ich verstehe es kann auch nicht ehrlich
gesagt ich habe schon oft gemacht hat
kommen auch die herzen es ist voll
reguliert ist ein us-schiff mainz revita
verbrennt das stehe nicht wie so was
nicht funktioniert dass das problem
revisionismus begann ja das haus klein
weg von rewe ich wollte sicher denkt
hier komme ich nicht durch klicks so
jetzt werde ich mich an mein haus nicht
räumen haus nämlich abgebaut
eigentlich bräuchte ich brauch nur das
an ich kann es gar nicht ich muss es
komplett abbauen
scheiße stimmt
verdammt clever ganz wenig nicht in
meinem land gegen notfalls gehe ich auch
zu fuß aber es wie gesagt versprochen
kilos dass ich das in den weg machen
wenn ihr das versprechen halte ich das
auch
hast du ne pc's mit touch dem opfer
seine gern dem opfer sollte ich zehn
sekunden nicht holz an geste kurz weiter
abbauen
kommt es wieder tötest kurz alle mit
einem schlag unter par stage selbst
klingt die haben einen die haben meinen
die hammer die haben wir in die haben
ein schwert aufgezogen widerstands so
nah dran
ja geil geil
scheiße mann ich will mein schwert gib
mir mein schwert ihr pizzas also mein
bogen das kann echt nicht sein also ich
komme dass schoko will einfach nicht ja
vielleicht hast du dich halt wirklich
das kann ja auch sein
nein darf es mich zu freuen und jetzt
mach ich mal den kölner fortune damit
ihr seht was das jetzt genau bringt
fahrgäste an und ich stelle es mal jetzt
hier ab und tun auch mal so und gibt dem
ein punk die sachen werden dazu
angezogen aber ich kann ja nicht alle
aufnehmen oder dem jetzt in hand mit
einmal ärger wird dann wieder herzen
kriegt vorlauf wann kommt die ganzen xp
auch wenn ich hier stehen und die
theoretisch abschießen
also wenn ich jetzt durch die gegend
laufe dann folgt ist zumindest dass er
nimmt das musst du das noch hinkriegen
dass die ganze zeit folgt ich habe meine
fresse reizwort bekommen hört die webcam
und einen fresse reizwort bekommen des
todes ist egal wir kriegen ja bald allen
goldenes ich hab das vergolden ist dem
planeten ist das egal
ich dachte hätten großes weißes oder so
bekommen
hör mir nicht zu machen obwohl die
heiligen blut muss gewahrt bleiben so
also ich habe ein schwert hatten mob
fallen gelassen und das schwert hat
einfach an breaking drei schafften es
fünf noch beck 23 und feiere es pack 2
von anfang an draufgehabt data ist das
krass was wenn jemand mein handy macht
nix ich habe schon wieder crew gehört
neben mein handy macht nix das ist
vielleicht ändert das ist vielleicht ein
chocobo oder so mein handy mal 1 8
prozent ein handy jetzt dass sie auch in
der audiospur nichts komme ich schmeiß
man jetzt auf mein bett drauf ja endlich
so sieht es auf meinem bett ich habe
fünf minuten kein nachricht bekommen
und du bildest dir sein jemand hört dass
in der aufnahme ich würde da seine ist
hier gar nicht existent du hast zu viele
von einem komischen pillen geschluckt er
halt auf dem einen steht ein schoko
goldenes tor
vielleicht könnte es meins werden wo sie
auch langlaufen
wenn ich jetzt mit weg macht auch nur
für chaos und der blutschande schuldig
werden was alter weil ich so viele
verbraucher jetzt fliehen weil ohne toko
bohrloch dahin reisen muss meinen schoko
in der stadt hing klassen verrät meine
position
stimmt er dass der eagles scheiße es
geht ja gar nicht du kannst es allgemein
nicht da lassen muss es ein bisschen weg
reiten und die koordinaten vielleicht
ausmachen
er muss ich zurück aber ich bin ja auch
noch nicht mal hin geräten ist sport das
zu kurz gekommen genauso war das nix
andere ist deswegen ist das komisch
verrückter center in ländern komischer
vorraum ist zum komischen grünholz sehr
dass sich jetzt erst für das was ich
mache
zwecks ja das ist wirklich komisch aus
habe ich auch wieso wie verrückt weil
sich das alter anders aus es ist die
gegen saeed sieht ein bisschen grünlich
aus wie ich noch mal zu sagen pflegt
nicht nichts grün und hast du wieder ein
komisches handy gehört alles blödsinn
sagt man demnächst mal weil dann dann
kann ich mal gucken was es hier ist ich
höre mir auch eine audiospur an das kann
nicht sein sagt dies ist wenn irgendwas
handy aktivität ist außerdem selbst wenn
du nix kriegt wenn dir das netz
aufrechterhalten mein lieber also dieses
fresse rights watch
das ist so geil dass die ganzen sachen
einfach schon drauf sind was kann denn
das ja da ich weiß also dass presse
rights watch ist ein ganz normales
schwert sowie ein krankentransport oder
so aber es hat einfach heftigste
verzauberungen darauf ersetzt nicht so
heftig also es hat fünf verschiedene
verzauberungen also etwas automatisch
beim drops schon
ja das war beim droppen das wort
getroffen ob das verhältnis heftig ich
hasse solche langen reisen und ich hab
jetzt schon zwei zauberstäbe verbraucht
aber steht sondern durch die paar sachen
noch einmal eben alles nur für kehraus
den bluechips lab
schuldet living mittel schielt wo kann
ich ja die schilder einpacken
ich habe schon ziemlich voll kaka für
mich darauf diese ständer war dieses
schild gepackt - platte wohl das schild
ist kurzweilig das bekommen so an ideen
mutter ihm anschließend eine mal wieder
ein paar mazda mx vergisst es nicht aus
dass wir vergessen das tor in gang
weißt du wie stark dieser kölner fortune
ist was denn ich habe die sachen in den
mülleimer getan und der kölner ford und
saugt die sachen da wieder raus ich muss
denn jetzt aus machen wenn ich was den
müll schmeißen alter wie ich weiß die in
den mülleimer ich weiß den müllerland
ist köln auf der sache raus ja der ist
hat seine heftige dings geil alter egal
also alle meine flugschreiber sind jetzt
weg an ihm habe ich noch alter drei
flugzeuge strebe wenn ich nicht gleich
sein haus plündern war weiß ich auch
nicht
wir sind eine soziale stadt
ja wir tun nicht alles für jeden hier
kommt das schwert rein wenn auf einer
höheren mächte und hier ist nämlich zum
frieden statt
zumindest da ungefähr so habe ich
siebzehn level dabei ist ich mache jetzt
auf meine spitzhacke touch was
eigentlich
ich will die ganzen glas dings
glasscheiben abbauen
sonics verschwenden genau damit nicht
wieder ganz viel sand farben gehen muss
so und nicht so leicht lasse ich das für
jedoch gesehen dass auf der minimap hier
muss es wichtig sei nicht mehr das war
irgendwo auf einer bühne aufstellen oder
so
fantastischen wüstenblume genommen hier
weil ich das hin knallen
und dann sah hier ist aber das portal
hat er sich abzufinden
so ist die kacke sie weg also ich denke
ich werde jetzt einfach mal die skoda
nehmen ich weiß nicht dass sie das steht
also einsam rum mit anonymous gelöste
wir dürfen uns sowieso welche nehmen und
ich habe ja noch kein oder doch ich hab
ein goldenes vielleicht ist das sogar
mainz goldes haben jobs damals genommen
sagte es ist sogar mainz
ich frage mich die konzept habe ich mich
dass nehmen dafür dass besitzer hammer
besitzer ist ein schoko oder hungern
ich dachte das projekt von evans
strafkicks über der königin was weiß ich
aber auch nix nix nix so hab ich hier
nix mit der stadt hamm ich klicks die
ganze zeit fünfmal beim fünften mal
möchten sie die 1 rast funktion
aktivieren york knicks jetzt einfach
mein leben lang nix
jetzt kriegt ihr das von mir die
koordinaten die königin mag uns beide am
liebsten käfig nicht so du schuld ist
mir zwei elektriker nch nur zwei total
es hier noch mehr
was hat die königin solle mehr fordern
so merkt hier mal königin hat gesprochen
dass ihr dann gesagt dass du mehr
fordern sonst so 1000 - 65
kanns mir mein haus weiter abzubauen
wunderbar jetzt habe ich würde
eigentlich gerne noch retten was einen
rettenden massekredit macht bei rewe die
die erde da gerade super
gemeinschaftliche aufgabe nämlich bei
rewe ja aber die erde müssen wir gerade
machen
das sonstige das heißt ja aber was mache
ich jetzt nur ein schoko ich habe auch
schon gedacht vielleicht in unserem
kölner hör mir mal zu in unserer
kompletten statt
anstatt erde als boden irgendwas anderes
zu nehmen wartete das abgeschrieben
das war geil wenn ich so immer die
herangezogenen noch erfahrung bekommen
würde mit den kölner fixe nähe kriege
ich nicht aber das war megageil
ok so also was reportedly aber hinter
mir her vielleicht auch schon foto dapd
ich dachte schon tot zehn tote
was einer ist das war ungerechtfertigt
ja den dänen den tod hatte ich ja auch
oder wartest du santos wo du geboren
bist und dann hat sogar jeder zweite ich
wollte ich habe mich jetzt ganz
regelkonform response aber nur weil ich
zu beginn durch den bug gestorben bin
und dann hat mich an bord sie modersohn
nochmal geflext also wenn ich so rum
fliege folgt ist mir einwand feinde
unglaublich ich glaube ich lasse es
einfach auf folgen
in der hoffnung dass wenn ich jetzt
einfach irgendwo und irgendwann fällt
der groschen ist teleportiert sich
freuen ich weiß nicht ob ich den shader
drin lassen soll oder nicht erinnern und
hat verdient also was soll ich tun wenn
ich diesen kader hier drinnen wartet
ganz bei re wie den wo das es gar nicht
komplett abgefackelt da oben baumeister
das abreißen und die erdige begnadete
begradigen ich habe hier schon die idee
in denen die kurve sondern gerade
gemacht irgendwie ein bisschen gerade
das heißt werde
und hier kommt man ein haus hin hier in
der mitte ross finde ich nicht fair
warum die zu groß petriplatz kommt halt
noch die essens links rein du hast doch
auch so ein großes haus ist nur die
reihe das ist ja das war ja nichts
geplant dass mein haus also das wird
auch nicht mein haus oder muss er jetzt
mein haus sein
ich weiß nicht genannten die normalen
anderes haus baue aber zack komplette
folge wenn der nächste
müssen reichen das sind das ist eine
komplette folge so wenn die nächsten
draufkommen dass sie sich denken hoch
passiert dann passiert so zu eine folge
ist es kein neues geld ob das reicht
nicht und jetzt doch glatt vergessen wo
ich ab glas und dass auch ein schreiben
blogs sehe ich gerade wie oft ich hatte
ja den normalen disco blog ja den hatte
ich auch aber dann habe ich erst gedacht
oder beleuchtete weil mir was auch den
gestellt hast du die reds an verklagt
darunter gestellt einfach ich weiß gar
nicht in welchem stil also natürlich den
stil weiß ich aber wie genau mein haus
aussehen soll
mach das jetzt wie folgt auch wenn es
irgend eigentlich kacke ist aber schau
mal ich brauche ja aber unter der ebene
ab und lasst dann einfach ein
zwischenprodukt das du noch ärgerlich
verloren kann
du bist du denn dabei leben ist ein
stück alt und günstig
ich habe bestimmt noch irgendwo erde
dann holst es mir weil ich ja aber keine
machen
na klar mein haus steht offen wie sonst
was
so erreichten doch es ist erst ein stall
reicht den spec nee nee lassen
1 tag geburtstag jetzt nicht reicht dann
reichen da muss ich halt noch weiter
machen aber ich hab den kunden aktiviert
er würde es mir durchaus wieder ein foul
aber dieser köln ist eigentlich echt
ganz geil wenn du weißt du wenn du
irgendwo einem dings bist und dem tower
einfach die kisten schnell abbauen mit
einer heftigen akt aber lasst doch
gesagt jetzt wieder raus und ist ein
service der dispenser der dispenser
schmeißt die sachen ja was stimmt aber
mit auf ihren weg zieht ihr die sachen
daraus okay das verständnis weil sie
krass ihr seid ja nicht weit aber was
ich ja geil finde ist dass der einfach
mal dass der gau wenn aus den kisten las
direkt ziehen würde
der mast als auch meiner erfahrung nach
so kriegserfahrung weiterzieht nähe
denen nicht wenn du ziehst nur du kannst
auch erfahrungen damit ziehen also wenn
erfahrung eigentlich ganz weit weg ist
das zum beispiel bei dem ogv alle ganz
gleich stellen ich mit meinem bogen
einfach ganz weit weg mit dem bogen
schießt gerne ab und die erfahrung
fliegt quasi zum innen dann haben ein
paar leute geschrieben das wir denn
machen sollen deshalb echt ganz geil
drauf passt auch seine haltbarkeit der
winzer nutzt oder wie ist es nur die art
kanal park hat der ist ja endlich
natürlich geil so ja ich weiß dass nach
gestern aus ich werde sicherlich schon
alle in den kommentaren
ich habe die halbe fläche so unterhöhle
das eigentlich gut aber dann sieht von
oben wenigstens keil aus ja da wird ja
eh nichts mehr großes angebot vielleicht
noch egal
wir werden da vielleicht eine arena hin
bauen und was als es wird er als auch
kommen wir entwickeln uns ja jetzt jetzt
ein neuer platz erreicht ich verweise
aber irgendwas x entwickelt vielleicht
sagt irgendwer aus stadtroda kommen ich
möchte gerne bei euch mal bohnen oder so
und dann aber richtig um team komplett
es gibt viele möglichkeiten was so
theoretisch passieren könnte komplett
umziehen kann man ja noch drüber reden
ja klar du hast ja das heute gar nicht
abgebaut
welches holz hier oben ja habe ich noch
gesagt das ist irgendwie erloschen waren
das feuer neues gemacht weil mein
fahrzeug kaputt wach
direkt alles an gzv expert das kurz
abzock die chillige alte variante also
normal man darf natürlich sagen ja ich
komme ja per in der stadt hier mit der
und der person zum beispiel nicht klar
und deswegen möchte ich gehen und blabla
und keine rechnung
das kann man natürlich mehr seiner kann
man auch darüber reden aber wenn man
sagt ja ich gehe jetzt in die stadt und
dann einen monat später schaltet oft in
die stadt zu gehen das ist ja nicht
richtig das ist kein vernünftiges
verhalten da muss man schon mal
konsequenzen ziehen das letzte haus
abgerissen haben aber dabei x3 holz eine
aufnahme läuft jetzt wieder
ich habe keine ahnung wo die
zwischendurch aufgehört ist schau mal
kurz aufnahmen einfach auch
zwischendurch ich habe wahrscheinlich
nichts gedrückt soll ich jetzt nein nein
ich nehme viel weiter
ja aber ich habe drauf hat das ist total
gegangen bin
das heißt bei ihr werdet ihr jetzt ich
werde mal zusammen schneiden also leute
hatten keine fehler macht irgendwo bin
ich außerdem auf die taste gekommen wo
ich das machen ja ich hab's ein komplett
aufgenommen von der salza kein problem
sein
genau das sieht ja dass dann bei luca
ich habe ich habe glaube ich nicht auch
nichts gemacht außer hier die erde
gesetzt und das portal in der mitte bei
der aufnahme ist auch weg
stell dir vor so zeit wieder ihr das gar
nicht gedrückt war wann hab ich gar
nicht kenne ich hatte ich auf meine ich
hab mir ist es passiert dass ich mal
nicht so wie ich mal so stadt kopfstand
unten links da wo ich mir den rechner
raus dann bist du einer der gras mark in
der stadt so also eigentlich nicht so
aber erhalt der stadtbus krott komplett
ab deswegen also ja deswegen ja
eigentlich nicht so ich möchte was ich
gesagt habe vielleicht dass wir einfach
das komplette gras was wir haben in der
stadt die durch irgendeinen anderen blog
austauschen
das lokal statt fein tun was denn jetzt
hat eine idee gekommen und zwar es ist
glaube ich nicht möglich dass das tor wo
sich zu mir teleportiert weil wenn ich
weggehe von der stadt diese stadt mehr
geändert ist wenn ich aber auch folgen
habe dugard rüttelte
es hat nur eine minute maximal 30
sekunden kommission mit rein als ich
hier rein voran
in welches portal beide in die gleichen
dimensionen ist nun sicherheitshalber
als einzelfirma weg geht so dass jetzt
statt pink eine neue dimension alten und
neuen leben
beim skylink kunstfest und jetzt gebe
ich dem norma den befehl follower
ich weiß dass auch mal ab hier ich weiß
dass hier mal ab genau jetzt gehe ich in
den befehl von genau confirm jetzt gehe
ich schnell rein müssen statt pink
sheets weit weg also richtig weit weg
ich reiße gerade den jacko nein
ok dann lasst ihr doch freuen ja es ist
bei mir naja das war es genau das war
geil alter ist müssen allerdings von uns
liegt kein gedanke du kannst ja das
portal zu rücken und dann bist du schon
wieder da hammer alter
das habe ich gemeint als darf ich als
dafür dass ich dir so toll geholfen
haben und einfach rum stand darf dafür
deine portal immer benutzen wird einfach
aber das ding ist du musst die so nutzen
dass die anderen das nicht wissen
auch wissen sie dass nicht nur die für
mich ja in jeder stadt auch in die
friedensstadt na klar mach ich hätte ja
auch mal mit abzureißen hier unsere
folge ist auch vorbei weil ja also ich
nicht aber ich doch doch ich hab ich
habe zwar ein fehler gemacht aber ich
hab ja 20 minuten spielzeit oder 90
minuten spielzeit jetzt gab deswegen ist
sie auch vorbei und am bürgerhaus an
leute die listen für euch auf euch jetzt
gefragt ob wir haben es jetzt nicht ganz
fertig gekriegt also ich glaube bei den
klassischen ausgetauscht oder wieder was
bei re wie ich es mal ganz anders hinten
auf meinem bett abgebaut du bist
natürlich bis behindert braucht er
einfach mitarbeiter egal dann total
jetzt ich hoffe mal dass ich nicht
sterben werde
das portal damit jetzt nach ja herr
stimmen damit spart man müsste direkt an
so sehr gut so sieht das jetzt bei rewe
auf dass das komplette haus von rewe ist
einfach weg
und bei mir ist jetzt noch nicht so viel
gebaut
bei mir kommt noch was das steht jetzt
erst mal nur das grobe grundgerüst da
werde ich jetzt hinter mir ist auch
schon ne menge weg ich habe mir die
sache ein bisschen verzaubert und wir
schauen jetzt mal das ganze von oman von
caps blog das größte was man leute
bleibt
ich hoffe ihr seid nimmst du das nicht
willst dass sich außerdem ausnahmen
knopf ausgedrückt habe das bewährte
vater gewesen sein
schaut einfach für die fehlenden
passagen bei luca vorbei links natürlich
wie immer in der beschreibung und
ansonsten sehen wir uns in der nächsten
folge wieder auf die ethische legende
geht weiter also leute bis dann was gut
katar